Jake Paul is probably going to beat you
and that's not saying that you're not an
incredible fighter clearly he's a
kickboxing world champion one of the
best kickboxers of his time there's no
doubt we know that for a fact if you've
done any training at all you know that
the instincts not just the muscles
atrophy the instincts do the timing you
take a year off the timing's not there
this guy Jake has been in the [ __ ]
ring now granted he's big I mean how
tall is Andrew six two probably they're
about the same height yeah I wouldn't do
it if I'm Andrew especially if you've
got 100 Mil in the bank there's no way
so who does Jake fight next Nate Diaz
that's the one that you would make Nate
Diaz because you want to Rattle up the
MMA crowd MMA is bigger than boxing so
it's like you want everybody in MMA to
be rooting for the MMA guy if you really
want to make things big it can't be just
you're following my fault you want
tribalism you want in-group out group
you want them and US bare minimum tribal
curiosity yep